american students talk about safe spaces
as shelter from ideas they dislike
chinese students need safe spaces to
learn of the ideas
that they love what a stark
contrast they know that left-leaning
college campuses are rife with any
americanism
and present easy targets for their
anti-american messaging
since 2013 the chinese have pumped a
billion dollars into our university
system
including generous gifts to elite
institutions like harvard and stanford
now in exchange our universities take in
about
370 000 chinese students
every year now this is a huge and great
deal for the ccp
but it's a disaster for us and as
congressman eric swalwell has learned
some of these students may have ulterior
motives
joining me now is senator marco rubio
acting senate intel committee chair
senator uh i think you say that these
latest revelations of
china's espionage it's all just
the tip of the iceberg so what should we
be looking for down the road well first
awareness people need that we've been
talking about this for a long time
remember four years ago when i started
going after the confucius institutes we
now have none left in florida we got a
lot of pushback
because universities would say oh this
is just a group that teaches chinese
language or
these are these are just uh people that
sponsor trips and when you explain to
people that the chinese are
they're the most holistic whole of
society threat this country's ever faced
in terms of espionage
i mean they will try to create
relationships with a small town mayor
who they think may one day
grow up to be a governor senator a u.s
member of congress
they will cultivate business
relationships they use business people
they take them to china they let them
make some money and then they unleash
them back in the u.s and use them as
lobbyists
here in this country for their interest
and against our national interests
they're in academia you talked about
students especially at the graduate
level a lot of these students that are
spying don't consider themselves spies
they're here they're serving their
country many are even linked to the
military they
they're researchers they steal secrets
and take it back and then you've got
american researchers
who have openly just sold their research
and oftentimes
leaving to china with it other times
just selling it to them
and and in many cases it wasn't illegal
or wasn't prosecuted
this is a big big challenge we have a
lot of work ahead of her
and senator john ratcliffe director of
national intelligence
today is quoted as issuing concerns
about what might be happening with
election meddling
coming from china we heard for about
russian election meddling for
years but now the concerns are fueled by
fresh intelligence
of what china's leaders either did or
planned to do
to keep trump from being re-elected some
analysts say that the new intelligence
will show that china's effort to
influence the us election was far more
extensive
than previously supported now senator
has your committee to the extent you can
tell us
seen anything to back this up
well let me just say months ago we
started saying the fact that china was
wanted to or had intentions to at least
be in a position to interfere in
elections and i mean by that
everything from putting out narratives
to divide us against each other
we also know that uh they had people out
there sort of trying to work to inject
things in a public discourse or
potentially in a position to do it
now obviously you know like you said i'm
not in a position to talk about all of
the suffice to say that
the chinese are capable of doing
anything any other country in the world
can do and i would argue that in some
cases they have the ability to do far
more
for we know the russians are proficient
at cyber warfare they're proficient at
hacking and they're proficient at
information and propaganda
but the chinese they can do all of that
plus
they actually have reporters they
actually have people in the media and in
academia
and in think tanks that will further
their narrative that will further the
chinese narrative because they're funded
by them because they've been
you know co-opted uh from years of
travel to china you name it
and uh and so i think that their
capabilities are greater than any other
country in the world
messing around with us not just in our
elections but in everything
senator other news tonight uh quite
significant
that hackers reportedly again i always
take this with a grain of salt but
tied to russia or going back to russia
attacked the national
nuclear security administration as well
as microsoft in three states
uh do we know for sure it was russia
number one eric swalwell's tweeting
about it we'll put it up on the screen
americans have heard this before so they
might be a little bit skeptical but
swalwall's saying while republicans are
losing their minds on trump island
the u.s government is being hacked
anyone want to tell the president maybe
i don't know protect their country and
their businesses affected
this is from a guy who was compromised
by a chinese madam spy
yeah and by the way the new york times
barely covered it the evening news on
most of the networks barely covered it
i mean just another example of how every
single day the national media
by and large for the most part will
further narratives that are
generate headlines that are bad for
republicans and source figure out a way
not to cover the ones that are bad for
the democrats but let me just say this
what we know so far and it's publicly
available you know a company named solar
wind
they're orion plug-in private company
provides a lot of security
online security to the private sector a
lot of agencies in government including
at the state and local level
and that was the method by which they
got into these systems
i still think that even as i speak to
you now we are learning more every
single day
about the scope of this intrusion it is
massive it is still
is i would argue probably persistent it
is still ongoing
uh it probably is unprecedented you saw
the bulletin tonight that
went out it's a grave risk to federal to
state to local governments
to critical infrastructure to the
private sector and as far as attribution
you know when you
attribute it to somebody you got to know
for sure because it's a very i mean this
is
you know almost i would argue an act of
war of an act of
war absolutely but let me just say it
was a patient effort it was
sophisticated
uh it was well funded and well resourced
and that indicates it was a nation state
these wasn't two guys in a basement in
north korea some were looking to steal
some cryptocurrency i mean this is a
very serious intrusion and we're
learning a lot more about it and we need
to learn a lot more about it we need to
take action
yeah senator uh it's great to see you
tonight have a merry christmas if we
don't talk to you before merry christmas
thank you